The last thing I want to go over before we close out the course are just some
tips and tricks to help you tune your solver settings and
another way of thinking of how to use the FBI case solver.
So as I previously mentioned, there are a lot of different settings that you can tweak and
change to adjust the pose of your character and get the solver working how you want.
But to avoid, you know, that parameter hell of tweaking all these different settings and
not being sure really what you're affecting anymore.
This is the recommended order of tuning your settings.
The first would be to adjust the root settings.
So adjusting that behavior drop down and tweaking the pre and pull root settings.
Then work on excluding the bones.
So removing calculations from the solver and just simplifying things for you.
Then you can adjust the pull chain alpha per effector.
So increasing this could help improve your results for more sparse bone chains.
Or decreasing this value could actually help improve results for a bit more of a complex skeleton system.
And remember to add preferred angles to your bones as well.
So these are just determining in which angle your bone should rotate when the AK chain is compressed.
These settings should help you fix any issues you have for the most common case scenarios.
But we can still make additional adjustments with some of the bone settings.
So tweaking things like rotation stiffness.
You can even lock down different axes of a joint if it should only rotate in one direction.
Like a robotic arm for example or anything that should act like a hinge.
And applying limits to your axes.
So this should be used a bit more of a last resort as adding too many of these will probably require you to increase the iterations.
Which makes things a little bit more costly.
And it has the potential to cause some unwanted results as your different settings might start fighting one another.
And another way of thinking about how to use the full body IK solver is actually to use it for a single IK chain.
It doesn't have to be full body all the time.
Now you do a slightly different setup for this.
So in this example with a tail you would set the base of your tail as the root of the solver.
So tail 01.
And then within the settings under the root behaviour drop down you would choose pin to input.
And that just means the root will be playing the character's current animation.
And the solver will be prevented from translating the IK chain around.